out of three like women are very picky
when it comes to look and some some
studies say that women are more picky
about looks than men
I think it's preference I think it's
just your preference and what your type
is some some girls women like bigger men
or men that are not athletic and some
men do like bigger set women it is your
preference some men like short women
some men like brunettes blonde hair it
just is your preference would you say we
can get honest data about what we prefer
based on dating apps
did you say that like it says something
about by and large because there's
that's the number one way people are
meeting nowadays would you say by and
large we can get some information about
what men and women look for 100 yeah
yeah yeah yeah so so women only swipe
right between five to fifteen percent of
the time where men swipe right 50
percent
so so women are much more selective and
picky than men
it's hard for you guys to articulate it
because you don't you wouldn't ever go
there and describe it you just wouldn't
is that also because men and women are
using dating apps to look for different
things personally I have never been on a
dating app I've been in two long-term
relationships since I've sort of you
know been old enough to be in serious
relationships whatever I've never dated
around I've never
um been on a dating app at all I've seen
it on my friend's phones but that's it
so I don't know whether men and women
are using it for different things are
men just using it to get laid and are
women using it because it's a normal
thing to find people now are they using
that to you know look for a long-term
relationship why are they being more
picky all I can look at is the results
and this is the number one way people
are meeting for long-term relationships
too I just wanted to I'm sure I'm sure
short-term I'm sure
I'm sure I mean when when dating apps
first came about that was kind of the
main thing that I was under the
impression useful so like tender yeah
yeah I think you make a good point
though like you that I would agree with
that that be the the intention of why
they're on the app changes things
because if you're looking to date
someone for something important or like
long term that I'm not swiping on 70
people like I'm more very concerted
decisions but if I'm just looking for
like oh what's happening tonight swipe
on everybody and see who responds right
but then to that what I will say as well
that I would say women are more likely
to go on dating apps looking for a
potential partner whereas men I think
they're a bit more kind of go with the
flow and you know see if a connection
comes it comes if it's just a hookup
it's just the hookup so that could be
also why they're scrolling more freely
than women I would say that's just the
men you see because like women don't see
no women don't like you don't know it
but like women don't see a large like
proportion of men in general like like
the men you want like they they
basically have their pick of the litter
so they don't want to settle down
they're only there for the short term
but like you think the one out of three
men that are virgins or haven't had sex
in the last year don't want a girlfriend
I'm sure that virgin could probably have
settled down yeah it could probably find
someone
again that's a very feminine point of
view because in your life like you've
always had access to sex that's easy but
men have to work to get sex they have to
become something to get sex I don't
think it would be a man's choice to not
have sex for a year like it's like
bottom line like today he might have
values and I think he could be waiting
for the right woman
I mean if a guy really wanted to just go
out and hook up with a girl depending on
where where obviously you go I'm sure
I'm positive there would be someone that
would go home with that man you have to
keep in mind even guys like Drake get
rejected like aggressively so if there's
no like it's it's unfortunate but there
are people who don't get any attention
any play and it just doesn't happen bro
I have to say like the majority of men
have to fight for that any attention
women get attention automatically men
have to go out even if you're attractive
in the top five percent you still have
to work 100 I think there's this
rejection on both sides yeah yeah I
think I think you're talking about
rejection as if it's exclusive just to
me I think okay let's talk about the
club the club front like just standing
around socializing there is no rejection
going on for any woman yeah there is I
guess I guess I guess yeah I understand
I guess if we're thinking about it in
the context of okay Club scenes
by and large talking stats again because
we like stuck stats here and Men
approaching women right is it not a form
of rejection if a woman doesn't get
approached by a man if that's the
standard way of doing it it's not a form
of right because the man has to go
towards it's like going to hunt for
something if I don't hunt that prize
what have I want yeah but don't you
think and what she wants if she's not
okay
um if they did an experiment where a
woman went up to 100
they did an experiment where a woman
went up to 100 men and asked for sex
and a man went up to 100 women and asked
if they wanted to have sex it was around
I want to say like 50 of men said yes
where two I think one two women maybe
said yes out of a hundred I think that
goes back to like the point that I was
trying to make like a man it's not going
to be his choice to not have sex yeah
yeah you're right because you know one
of the things that men are built for is
to procreate and you know like that
includes having sex they want to do that
all the time from you know that moment
that they hit puberty regardless of who
it's with that's what they want to do so
they're gonna say yes and flip the
question around if it was a hundred
women asking man to be married like I
think you'd get kind of a similar
similar result the other thing guys are
jumping for marriage one out of three I
think one out of three would say hell
yeah like I'm sorry to to say it's
comparable the rate women face
rejections do you cut but you're
comparing it so so you're implying that
it is but I'm just emphasizing the whole
like their difference like I think guys
are skewed more towards like I would
rather have sex than be married right
skewed towards rather something more
committed than sex well women I don't
know if that was a comparison but I see
your point yeah thank you yeah but women
women only women only get rejection out
of like from the top 20 guys they just
don't want to go to the bottom 80.
that's true and even coming back on our
point there our debate I just thought
about it you had a mind blowing moment
a minute
a factor if that's rejection that's a
beautiful rejection oh someone didn't
come up to me but every majority of
women do get approached so it's still
better odds in in comparison to men oh
it's still just I was entertaining the
fact that if that's how if that's the
context we're talking about because you
spoke about a club scene right yeah I
guess the rejection can come in many
different ways I was just using that
example because you said it I mean if I
if I got that form of rejection I'd be
quite happy I'll be like okay no one
actually told me no but no one didn't
approach me I'd still be hurt I'd still
be there especially if I'm gonna club
with all my boys and all my boys are
getting approached and I'm not getting a
Frozen like ah well let's be honest no
ladies are approaching men like that
it's true and that mass form yeah it's
just not gonna happen yeah but I
wouldn't take it as a badger honor like
oh yeah wait hold on sorry are you
saying that like
um that women don't appreciate it just
just approach men well of course
nowadays because
quite high now I find a lot of women not
me specifically but I'm saying I find
quite a lot of women nowadays you'll be
out and they're very keen to approach
okay what clubs are you talking about
because I'll take it
very small percentage or good looking
enough that women will approach them by
and large there are there are some men
like I know a couple guys that get
approached on a regular basis but
yeah they're top they're very very good
looking guys some might say I do think
yeah
um speaking speaking of top G
um we are gonna react to one of his
clips
um that people had a problem